Il y a six ans,
j'ai découvert quelque chose
que les scientifiques veulent savoir depuis des années.
Comment retenir l'attention
d'une salle pleine d'adolescents qui s'ennuient profondément ?
Il s'avère que vous n'avez qu'à évoquer le mot « pornographie ».
(Rires)
Laissez-moi vous dire comment j'ai découvert cela.
En 2012, j'étais assise dans une pièce pleine de lycéens
qui suivaient un programme parascolaire à Boston.
Ma tâche, en tant qu'intervenante pour la journée,
était de les encourager à penser à l'aspect enthousiasmant
d'une carrière dans la santé publique.
Le problème,
en regardant leurs visages,
était que je voyais leurs yeux devenir vitreux
et ils décrochaient.
Cela n'importait pas que je porte
ce que je pensais être une tenue cool ce jour-là.
Je perdais mon public.
Puis l'un des deux adultes travaillant pour le programme a dit :
« Ne faites-vous pas de recherche sur la pornographie ?
Parlez-leur peut-être de cela. »
Tout à coup, cette salle pleine de lycéens a explosé de rire et en exclamations.
Je crois qu'il y a eu des hululements retentissants.
Prononcer un seul mot - « pornographie » - avait suffi.
Ce moment allait s'avérer être un moment déterminant
pour moi et ma mission professionnelle : trouver des solutions
pour mettre fin à la violence relationnelle et sexuelle.
A ce stade-là, j'avais travaillé pendant plus d'une décennie
sur ce problème apparemment insoluble de la violence dans les relations.
Des données des centres pour le contrôle et la prévention des maladies
démontrent qu'un jeune allant au lycée sur cinq
est victime de maltraitance physique et/ou sexuelle
de la part d'un partenaire aux États-Unis chaque année.
Cela fait que la violence relationnelle est plus fréquente
que le harcèlement à l'école,
les pensées suicidaires sérieuses
ou même le fait de vapoter
dans cette même population.
Mais les solutions s'avéraient élusives.
Je travaillais avec une équipe de recherche
qui chassait de nouvelles réponses à la question :
qu'est-ce qui occasionne la maltraitance relationnelle
et comment y mettre un terme ?
L'une des études sur lesquelles nous travaillions à l'époque
s'est avérée comprendre quelques questions sur la pornographie.
Quelque chose d'inattendu émergeait de nos découvertes.
11% des adolescentes de notre cohorte
ont déclaré avoir été forcée ou menacée
de faire des choses que l'auteur avait vues dans de la pornographie.
Cela a éveillé ma curiosité.
Fallait-il blâmer la pornographie
pour un pourcentage de la violence relationnelle ?
Ou était-ce plutôt une coïncidence que les consommateurs de pornographie
s'avéraient avoir plus de risques d'être dans des relations malsaines ?
J'ai enquêté en lisant tout ce que je pouvais
issu de la littérature
et en conduisant ma propre recherche.
Je voulais savoir
quels contenus sexuellement explicites les jeunes regardaient,
à quelle fréquence et pourquoi
et voir si je pouvais établir
que cela expliquait en partie pourquoi, pour tant d'entre eux,
les relations amoureuses étaient apparemment malsaines.
En lisant, j'ai essayé de garder l'esprit ouvert
même si de nombreux membres du grand public
s'étaient déjà fait une opinion sur le sujet.
Pourquoi garder l'esprit ouvert au sujet de la pornographie ?
Je suis experte en sciences sociales,
c'est mon travail d'être objective.
Mais j'ai également une approche positive de la sexualité.
Cela signifie que je soutiens le droit des gens
à jouir de la vie sexuelle et de la sexualité qui les satisfont,
peu importe ce que cela implique,
tant que cela comprend le consentement enthousiaste
de toutes les parties concernées.
Cela étant dit, je n'étais personnellement pas encline à regarder de la pornographie.
J'en avais vu, cela ne m'avait rien fait du tout.
En tant que mère de deux enfants presque adolescents,
j'avais mes inquiétudes
au sujet des effets que regarder de pornographie pourrait avoir sur eux.
J'ai remarqué que s'il y avait beaucoup de gens
qui dénonçaient la pornographie,
il y avait aussi de fervents défenseurs pour différentes raisons.
Dans mon exploration académique,
j'ai réellement essayé de comprendre :
la pornographie était-elle mauvaise ou bonne pour vous ?
Était-elle misogyne ou responsabilisante ?
Aucune réponse n'est ressortie de façon claire.
Il y a eu une étude longitudinale qui m'a vraiment inquiétée
et qui montrait que les adolescents ayant vu de la pornographie
avaient ultérieurement plus de risques de commettre de la violence sexuelle.
Mais la conception de l'étude
ne permettait pas d'établir des conclusions causales définitives.
Il y avait d'autres études n'ayant pas trouvé
que la consommation de pornographie
était associée à des conséquences négatives spécifiques.
Même si d'autres études avaient montré cela.
Mais en parlant à d'autres experts,
j'ai ressenti une énorme pression
pour prendre parti au sujet de la pornographie.
Rejoindre une équipe ou l'autre.
On m'a même dit que j'étais faible d'esprit
à ne pas pouvoir choisir une bonne réponse
au sujet de la pornographie.
C'était compliqué
car il y a une industrie
qui fait de l'argent sur la fascination du public
à regarder des femmes en particulier,
non seulement avoir des relations sexuelles,
mais être étranglées, bâillonnées, giflées,
se faire cracher dessus, se faire éjaculer dessus,
être appelées par des noms dégradants à répétition durant un rapport sexuel
et pas toujours avec un clair consentement de leur part.
La plupart des gens s'accorderaient à dire que nous avons un gros problème
de misogynie, de violence sexuelle et de viols dans ce pays
et la pornographie n'aide probablement pas avec tout cela.
Un problème d'une importance capitale à mes yeux était
que pendant plus d'un siècle,
la position anti-pornographie a été utilisée comme prétexte
de discrimination à l'encontre des gays et des lesbiennes
ou des gens qui ont des goûts coquins ou des fétiches.
Je pouvais voir pourquoi, d'un côté,
nous pourrions beaucoup nous inquiéter des messages transmis par la pornographie
et, d'un autre côté,
nous pourrions beaucoup nous inquiéter d'exagérer en l'accusant.
Les deux années suivantes,
je me suis penchée
sur toutes les allégations effrayantes, horrifiantes que j'ai pu trouver
sur l'âge moyen auquel les gens voient de la pornographie pour la première fois,
l'effet que cela a sur leur cerveau ou sur leur sexualité.
Voici ce dont j'ai à rapporter.
La pornographie gratuite et dominante en ligne,
que les adolescents ont le plus de chances de voir,
est une terrible forme d'éducation sexuelle.
(Rires)
(Applaudissements)
Mais elle n'était pas prévue pour ça.
Et elle n'empoisonne probablement pas instantanément leur esprit
ni ne les transforme en consommateurs compulsifs
comme certains idéologues aimeraient vous le faire croire.
Très peu de personnes ne voient pas de pornographie dans leur jeunesse.
D'ici à leurs 18 ans,
93% des étudiants en première année et 62% des étudiantes en première année
ont vu de la pornographie au moins une fois.
Même si les gens aiment dire
qu'Internet a rendu la pornographie omniprésente
ou garantit que tout jeune enfant
à qui l'on a donné un téléphone va voir de la pornographie,
les données ne le confirment pas.
Une étude représentative à l'échelle nationale
a découvert que durant l'année 2000,
16% des jeunes de 10 à 13 ans
ont déclaré avoir vu de la pornographie durant l'année.
En 2010, ce chiffre avait augmenté,
mais seulement jusqu'à 30%.
Il ne s'agissait donc pas de tout le monde.
Nos problèmes avec les adolescents et la perpétration de violence sexuelle
ne sont pas uniquement dus à la pornographie.
Une étude récente a découvert que les adolescents
ont plus de chances de voir des images sexualisées
dans tous les autres genres de médias à part la pornographie.
Pensez à tous ces jeux vidéo sexualisés, ces séries télé, ces clips musicaux.
Ce pourrait être l'exposition à un flot continu de médias violents
qui à la place de, ou en plus des images sexualisées, entraîne nos problèmes.
En nous concentrant uniquement
sur les nuisances potentielles de la pornographie,
nous passons peut-être à côté de problèmes plus importants.
Ou des causes premières
de la violence relationnelle et sexuelle, qui est une vraie crise de santé publique.
Cela étant dit, même ma propre recherche
démontre que les adolescents se tournent vers la pornographie
pour de l'éducation et des informations sur le sexe.
C'est parce qu'ils ne parviennent pas à trouver
des informations fiables et factuelles ailleurs.
Moins de 50% des États des États-Unis
exigent que l'éducation sexuelle soit enseignée à l'école,
y compris comment éviter les relations sexuelles forcées.
Et moins de la moitié de ces États
exigent que les informations présentées soient exactes d'un point de vue médical.
Dans ce programme parascolaire de Boston,
ces enfants voulaient vraiment parler de sexe
et ils voulaient vraiment parler de pornographie.
Ils voulaient parler de ces choses-là
bien plus qu'ils ne voulaient parler de violence relationnelle ou sexuelle.
Nous avons réalisé
que nous pouvions traiter des mêmes sujets dont nous parlerions normalement
sous couvert d'une éducation pour des relations saines :
quelle est la définition du consentement sexuel ?
Comment savez-vous si vous blessez quelqu'un durant un rapport sexuel ?
Quelles sont les limites saines à avoir quand vous flirtez ?
Nous pouvions discuter de ces mêmes choses
en utilisant la pornographie
comme point de départ de notre conversation.
C'est comme quand les adultes donnent un dessert aux enfants
mais ont secrètement inclus une courgette ou quelque chose de sain dedans.
(Rires)
Nous pouvions parler aux enfants des trucs sains,
de ce qui est bon pour eux,
mais le dissimuler dans une conversation au sujet d'une chose
dont ils pensaient qu'ils voulaient parler.
Nous avons découvert une chose
que nous ne n'avions pas nécessairement prévu de trouver :
la pornographie est un moyen formidable
d'avoir une conversation avec des adolescents
au sujet de la pornographie.
En maintenant la conversation fidèle à la science.
En admettant ce que nous savons et ce que nous ignorons
sur l'influence de la pornographie.
En parlant des résultats mitigés
ou des faiblesses des études qui ont été conduites.
En invitant les adolescents à devenir des consommateurs critiques
de la littérature de recherche sur la pornographie
ainsi que de la pornographie.
Cela convient vraiment au développement des adolescents.
Les adolescents aiment remettre des choses en question
et ils aiment être invités à réfléchir par eux-mêmes.
Nous avons réalisé en commençant à expérimenter,
à enseigner des cours sur le consentement, le respect et la pornographie,
qu'essayer d'effrayer les adolescents
pour qu'ils adoptent un certain point de vue
ou de leur faire avaler de force
un argument unilatéral sur la pornographie,
non seulement cela ne fonctionne probablement pas,
mais cela ne donne pas un exemple
du genre de comportement respectueux et consensuel
que nous voulons qu'ils apprennent.
Notre approche, ce que nous appelons la culture pornographique,
c'est présenter la vérité au sujet de la pornographie
d'après ce que nous avons,
étant donné qu'il y une fondation qui change constamment.
Quand les gens entendent
que nous enseignons un cours de neuf sessions, 18 heures,
de culture pornographique à des adolescents,
je pense qu'ils pensent soit que nous faisons asseoir les enfants
pour leur montrer comment regarder de la pornographie,
ce qui n'est pas le cas,
ou que nous faisons partie d'un groupe activiste anti-pornographie
qui essaye de les convaincre que s'ils ont vu de la pornographie,
cela est la pire chose qu'il soit pour leur santé.
Ce n'est pas non plus le cas.
Notre ingrédient secret est que nous ne donnons pas de leçons.
Nous ne pensons pas que la jeunesse devrait regarder de la pornographie.
Mais surtout, nous voulons qu'elle ait un esprit critique
si et quand elle en voit.
Nous avons appris
du nombre de demandes pour notre cursus et notre formation
venant de tous les États-Unis et d'au-delà,
qu'il y a beaucoup de parents et beaucoup d'enseignants
qui veulent vraiment avoir
des conversations plus nuancées et réalistes
avec les adolescents au sujet de la pornographie.
Nous avons eu des demandes venant de l'Utah jusqu'au Vermont,
de l'Alabama, d'Hawaï.
Dans ce programme parascolaire,
ce que j'ai vu, c'est qu'à l'instant où nous évoquons la pornographie,
ces enfants étaient prêts à entrer en conversation
au sujet de ce qu'ils voulaient ou non voir dans la pornographie
et ce qu'ils voulaient ou non faire durant un rapport sexuel.
Et ce qui était dégradant pour les femmes,
injuste envers les hommes ou raciste, tout cela.
Ils ont avancé des arguments très sophistiqués.
Exactement le genre de choses dont nous voudrions qu'ils parlent
en tant qu'activistes pour la prévention de la violence.
En tant qu'enseignants, nous pourrions quitter la classe un jour en pensant :
« C'est vraiment triste qu'il y ait ce garçon dans notre classe
qui pense que toutes les femmes ont des orgasmes via le sexe anal. »
Et nous pourrions quitter la classe la semaine suivante en pensant :
« Je suis contente qu'il y ait cet enfant homosexuel dans notre classe
qui a dit que voir sa sexualité représentée dans la pornographie
lui a sauvé la vie. »
Ou : « Il y a cette fille dans notre classe
qui a dit qu'elle se sentait mieux par rapport à son corps
car elle a vu quelqu'un avec ses formes être l'objet du désir
dans de la pornographie insipide. »
Voici où je suis en tant qu'activiste pour la prévention de la violence.
Je me retrouve à parler et à faire des recherches sur la pornographie.
Même s'il serait plus simple
si tout était blanc ou noir,
j'ai découvert durant mes conversations sur la pornographie avec des adolescents
qu'ils demeurent impliqués dans ces conversations
car nous leur permettons de débattre des complexités.
Et car nous sommes honnêtes au sujet de la science.
Ces adolescents ne sont peut-être pas encore des adultes,
mais ils vivent dans un monde d'adultes.
Et ils sont prêts pour des conversations d'adultes.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)